[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la fois où je me suis fait piéger sur le plateau avec une
fausse araignée
[Musique]
Je suis Spiderman Spiderman personne ne peut
m'arrêter avec ma poêle ouais
oh
oh mec je suis à bout de souffle
[Rires  ]
ah allez
je sais que tu profites de ton bain moussant
mais il est temps de sortir d'accord allez d'accord
tu veux encore cinq minutes d'accord d'accord
10 minutes de plus
regarde tes 10 minutes sont terminées viens
deux minutes de plus
trois minutes de plus
je suis  ne négociez pas pour plus disons que
vous ne négociez pas pour plus quoi de neuf
ces citrouilles sont pour des citrouilles sculptées
pour Halloween vous collez des bougies et mettez des
visages étranges dessus vous ne cuisinez pas
à l'intérieur de ces choses c'est une
recette de poulet sans tout un tas de déjà
ail haché ail haché
roulez-le et faites-le tourbillonner allons chercher notre
poulet j'ai l'impression que tu transpires mon
palais ouais non tu ne vas pas
le mettre là-dedans oh
non
non bonjour allons-y non c'est
effrayant allons-y  petit gars petit gars
sérieusement c'est g  Je vais être fou tout le
reste des oignons là-dedans non oh allez merci